[Music]
in crazy pay disparity news submitted by
the visionaries a crazy rich Asians
co-writer steps down from the sequel
after a pay disparity dissipate oh I
heard about this - we do white people
yes the co-star was nice I won't you
explain it oh okay okay I'll be like
you've always chipping us down good
movie by the way it was such a good
movie did we watch the same movie I
loved it Gina did the editor on that
movie should pretty bit higher yeah I
think you never showed up I'm like they
didn't edit this movie at all bro it's
like a giant run-on sentence oh you're
just saying that cause you're not a this
is I'm white I'm jealous I'm just
waiting for my Singaporean rich man to
come get me goddammit that's what you
like but you min the fantasy I bought
that right like the movie itself I'm
like this feels I bought into the fans
of fantasy and I ran anyway you guys
don't have good taste cuz I had a blast
yeah I had a blast too I'm just saying
if I'm gonna judge it for like this
that's true it [ __ ] suck but it was a
fun movie
yes I'm Asian but I'm [ __ ] do that
[ __ ] hey they're gonna say that about
your movie too anyway so it's fine I
don't care I want people to do it you
know why because I want to go through
the same scrutiny as everybody else
because I want to do better
yeah it felt like they gave him a gold
star the budget was obviously tight Joe
[ __ ] art direction the art direction
was amazed during the wedding part the
wedding part but they had like yeah I
strive to be that extra it was so funny
I can't wait to go to your wedding
I don't care where the guy is I don't
care if you have a hammer my cat [ __ ] go
to your wedding it got as successful as
it did because I don't think it was
undeserved it was a great fun movie to
just watch and on top of that it opened
up so many more doors for so many people
think about the top of that Jemma
bro she is so hot and that accent is
real whole what was it the Asian Ellen
in that movie yeah she's in some
controversy right now - on on black
Twitter people don't like that she kind
of had this hip-hop kind of vibe or like
with you grew up in Brooklyn yeah dude
well as soon as like kind of she started
getting more famous she kind of just
immediately dropped that kind of accent
or kind of like oh you used us to come
up what you're telling me you didn't
really have that urban twang in your
voice and you sound white how dare you
flaws she needed calm down well there's
Akana
she's on Admiral or something dude I
wanna say to me of like da really a
finding Dory movie like you're watching
a movie where people are playing it
straight and and this chick comes in
like Louie Louie and you're like wat da
[ __ ] she was a comedian
really yeah like was who is the lead
actress Constance yeah right in my brain
ball I've typed Casa der as the mom and
I use fresh off the boat yeah this young
girl it's looking for a husband and like
but your mom it's weird for me you could
be a mom and getting married like she's
she's like an older mom you know she
yells at you about your homework and
your math and oh it's you and Kumaon and
now I used to be a Kumaon coach like a
coolant teacher
gosh she is a nerd I am a nerd because
so [ __ ] nerdy
the writer so this co-writer so her name
is Adel Lim and she left the sequel
projects because all ya because um there
were a lot of negotiations trying to
have like going on because she felt like
she wasn't getting paid her fair share
because her white co-writer a partner
she was getting paid 800,000 to a
million because he was white when she
won because he's white so she was
getting offered a hundred and ten
thousand plus for Adel but the thing is
here that her the coat the white dude he
had done 2009's the proposal and so
they're saying like base off of
experiences like his writing credits
adele had only written TV like she's a
veteran TV writer this is the first time
she actually did a feature wait so his
rate was just higher in general because
of experience industry standard so like
the proposal killed it at the box office
and that that helps boost YC yeah normal
yeah rate goes up crazy but then for her
she just felt like well that's not fair
we're doing these sequels i was part of
the first like the crazy rotations and
so like of that success like i should
get me the other thing is though he had
already written three drafts of crazy
rich Asians before she joined that
project wow this is an original thing
this is an expanding that's why I'm just
like like you when you read all the
facts I'm like I don't know I'm not I
don't know I don't like to judge those
things because you don't have enough
information yeah exactly and like pay
disparities are hurt like that's like a
huge pain disparity and for someone
that's gonna be co-writing this yeah
because what Lee what I read about this
is that the the lady's argument is that
her writing helped with the integrity
and authenticity of the movie which he
couldn't bring or whatever she called it
like because she's treated like a soy
sauce like um like you sprinkle it on
this so she said being evaluated that
way can't help but make you feel that
this is how they view my contribution
right
women and people of color are often
regarded as soy-sauce hired to sprinkle
culturally specific details on a
screenplay rather than credited with the
substantive stance ative work of
crafting the story
well the story has nothing to do with
the cultural stuff right like as far as
like guy meets girl girl is gonna get
married right it looked all that stuff
is story now when you inject like the
you know the relationships and like all
that stuff is where cultural stuff comes
in and so I think that they're both
right you know I mean yeah I think it's
a difference in value and on top of that
like how you're determining what is more
valuable the pay or experience or and
hit I mean his agent could have just
been better
well if his agent could have negotiated
a higher rate routes as this movie made
to our mill and they're gonna kick 100
grand at her like that is like nothing
compared to he's getting like a million
yeah and he offered to give happy so
that's the things I'm saying um Peter P
half that means like 400 grand huh see
what if he will give it at half the Kami
I only heard a portion just let his fee
but I don't know I heard his hat well
it's not a hundred percent so I'm not
happy with that yeah but she passed on
it so she said Pete has been nothing but
incredibly gracious but what I make
shouldn't be dependent on the generosity
of the white guy writer if I couldn't
get paid equity after crazy rich Asians
I can't imagine what it would be like
for anyone else
given that the standard for how much
you're worth is having established
quotes from previous movies which women
of colors would never have been hired
for there's no realistic way to achieve
true equity that way so a lot of people
are saying that she um she has more
credits than him on IMDB which isn't
because she wrote for TV right have to
mean more crediting her right exactly
it's a I have a lot of MDB means you
could just put you put whatever the [ __ ]
you know I have credits I didn't even
earn like Inside Edition and stuff where
I think she's brand yeah is how much
money that how much
that much and that she gets a hunter
cake come on bro for the seat it should
be based off of that it should be based
off of your credibility as a writer
based off of how much money that yeah
that was a huge box like everyone should
give back kicked a hundred thousand
dollars well I think they need a
restructure because this is like old
business thinking Jen right you
basically like hey [ __ ] inventor I'm
gonna you invented this bottle I'm gonna
pay you for the licensing and the rights
for that I'll give you ten grand or
whatever and then with that I'm gonna go
out and sell [ __ ] billions of it right
same concept with her it's like writer
what is your rate okay I'll pay you for
that rate and if it does well then it's
all on me but we structure things a
little bit differently here because I
think that what would be cool is they're
like you give them their rate but then
you also give them a percentage [ __ ]
yeah
yeah but riders get [ __ ] in the
industry yeah writers do good fun they
get [ __ ] the hardest Anna and they're
the least respected babies we're we're
the least respected on the whole totem
pole yeah like as far as like okay we're
gonna pay you for you know what you did
to this movie if you have a percent of
gross or whatever you get paid like in a
year or more like it can be not
sometimes you get money before you start
writing the script yeah but did you get
a certain percentage of it and then when
you deliver it you get a certain
percentage of that but then you get like
the real money comes later and then you
don't even know when the [ __ ] is going
so people also don't know that the
production house to this is the game
that they play they play the game of
quantity so they're hoping that by
banking all of these films one of them
will have tremendous success such as
this but most films are lucky to break
even
you know most films that's what people
don't understand is that they're burning
[ __ ] money and then they like
majority of them won't we'll make money
on these like Marvel films right and
that's all they see but what about all
the movies that are turned out every
[ __ ] week at the theaters that a lot
of them don't make that much money or
they break even and writers are so
diamond dozen to Hollywood not to people
like me cuz I'm like I know writers are
[ __ ] though but to Hollywood they're
like hey you don't like it you don't
wanna take our grand
you're fired we'll find somebody else in
two seconds you're not gonna want to
[ __ ] come Cole right on a movie
that's how actors are - exactly so
burned especially if you're a non-union
that's why the union was established in
the first place your riders have unions
yeah who's the writers do writers guild
oh right I've heard of that but that was
a there was a huge strike and it did
affect Hollywood so that's the [ __ ]
rights or something I whip this chick
because nobody who [ __ ] rotor to her
mind on movie should get so [ __ ]
lowball yeah so isn't she the only Asian
like writer on the entire team uh so
like this whole movie is supposed to be
an Asian like coming-out thing like
Asians are now blockbuster hitter type
of people but there's just it's just a
white guy that's writing it doesn't it
seem weird well the actual story is from
Kevin Kwan he wrote the novel and in but
I mean he's still writing the movie was
yeah adapted by that guy I forgot his
name
uh Jon Chu no no he's the director yeah
the directors don't you the other guy is
Peter - oh really yeah this guy yeah
that guy isn't it weird though like this
is supposed to be an Asian thing I
personally like the female Asian writer
is now gone so that's like is it all
coming through him oh you mean the
sequels a whole team of agents telling
my story cuz I'm like you know I mean
can I get at least one white person in
there so that they don't make the wrong
[ __ ] well that's the thing that
people don't understand is that's how
it's always been
I mean Last Samurai or whatever like
it's all been a whole team of white
people writers whatever creating these
ethnic stories like yeah I mean think
about the original one Madame Butterfly
or whatever they did that whole theater
piece yeah you ever see the back story
on Moana
I was watching like the extra extra bits
or whatever and they like did like three
years or something but it's like a team
of like was like white American people
but they went to like Tahiti and they
like worked with the locals and stuff
but that's like that's how they wrote
yes they try their best to keep the
cultural integrity but it is a bit weird
and I think it's just gonna take our
people to be more encouraged and go out
and write their own stories and find
funding our own
way cuz right now with technology we can
do it you know that's what we're trying
to do do what's gonna be sick though
there's gonna be there's an oncoming
explosion gonna happen and in the movie
industry I think yeah because the
technology that it takes to produce a
movie is gonna get cheaper and cheaper
and cheaper like the point where people
have green screens in their homes now
yeah like just wait till all that [ __ ]
gets upgraded to where you're making
like cinema style graphics like
integrated easily you do a motion for
very cheap yep yeah the other one can
represent their own culture so you don't
have gatekeepers anymore yep yeah
compete with Hollywood and real quick
real quickly I just want to say that I
think that this lady
if the director truly has her back
because he says that he does he says he
has her back people saying I was in that
room and he did not know what I'm
[ __ ] saying so if he really had her
back she would already be hired on the
exact period Jon Chu yeah taunt you
shame on you shame on you shame on you
because the directors in charge man you
could hire the [ __ ] one so that's
that when he says he's with her prove it
like that's ridiculous
[Music]